each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so it's my great pleasure to
introduce Wes Weimer who's going to be
who is visiting us with Stephanie
Forrest and what is going to talk today
about automatically preparing bugs and
programs excellent okay thank you for
the introduction so I'm gonna be talking
about automatically finding patches
using genetic programming or to put it
another way automatically repairing
programs using genetic programming and
this is joint work with Stephanie forest
from the University of New Mexico and
our grad students klaren vu so in an
incredible surprise move for Microsoft
researchers I will claim that software
quality remains a key problem and
there's an oft-quoted statistic from the
past that suggests that over 1/2 of 1%
of the u.s. GDP goes to software bugs
each year would appear that there are
people in the audience familiar with
this statistic and that programs tend to
ship with known bugs often hundreds or
thousands of them that are triage to be
important but perhaps not worth fixing
with the resources available what we
want to do is reduce the cost of
debugging reduce the costs associated
with fixing bugs that have already been
identified in programs previous research
suggests that bug reports that are
accompanied by an explanatory patch even
if it's tool created even if it might
not be perfect are more likely to be
addressed rapidly that is that it takes
developers less time and effort to
either apply them or change them around
a bit and then apply them so what we
want to do is automate this patch
generation for defect in essence to
transform a program with a bug into a
program without a bug but only by
modifying small relevant parts of the
program so the big thesis for this work
is that we can automatically and
efficiently repair certain classes of
defects in off-the-shelf uh Nana Tate
idli Jassi program so we're going to be
taking existing seed programs like FTP
servers send mail web servers that's
that sort of thing and try to repair
defects in them the basic idea for how
we're going to do this is to
sitter the program and then generate
random variants explore the search space
of all programs close to that program
until we find one that repairs the
problem intuitively though this search
space might be very large so we're going
to bring a number of insights to bear to
sort of shrink this search space to
focus our search the first key part is
that we're going to be using existing
test cases both to focus our search on a
certain path through the program but
also to tell if we're doing a good job
with automatically creating these
variants will assume that the program
has a set of test cases possibly a
regression test suite that encodes
required functionality that make sure
that the program is doing the right
thing and we'll use those test cases to
evaluate potential variants in essence
we prefer variants that pass more of
these test cases then we're going to
search by randomly perturbing parts of
the program likely to contain the defect
you might have a large program but we
hypothesize that it's unlikely that
every line in the program is equally
likely to contribute to the defect we're
going to try to narrow down localize the
fault as it were and only make
modifications in specific areas so how
does this process work out you give us
as input the source code to your program
standard C program as well as some
regression tests that you currently pass
that encode required behavior so for
example if your program is a web server
these positive regression test cases
might encode things like proper behavior
when someone asks you to get index dot
HTML basic stuff like that in addition
you have to codify or quantify for us
the bug that you want us to repair so
there's some input upon which the
program doesn't do the right thing it
loops forever it's seg faults it's
vulnerable to some sort of security
attack and by taking a step back we can
actually view that as another test case
but one that you don't currently pass
all right so there's some input we have
some expected output but we don't
currently give the expected output we
then loop for a while doing genetic
programming work we create random
variants of the program we run them on
the test cases to see how close they are
to what we're looking for and we repeat
this process over and over again
retaining variants that pass a lot of
the test case
possibly combining or mutating them
together at the end of the day we either
find a program variant that passes all
of the test cases at which point we win
we declare moral victory we take a look
at the new program source code and
perhaps take a dip of it and the
original program and that becomes our
patch or we might give up since this is
a random or heuristic search process
after a certain number of iterations or
after a certain amount of time and say
we're unable to find a solution
we can't prepare the program given these
resource bounds so for this talk I will
speak ever so briefly about genetic
programming what it is what those word
means what those words mean and then
talk about one key insight that we use
to limit the search space our notion of
the weighted path and this is where
we're going to look for the fault or the
defect in the program I'll give an
example of a program that we might
repair an example perhaps near and dear
to the hearts of people in this audience
and then I'll present two sets of
experiments one designed in general to
show that we can repair many different
programs with sort of large cloud large
and different classes of defects and one
to try to get at the quality of the
repairs that we produce would anyone
trust them are they like what humans
would do might they cause you to lose
transactions or miss important work if
you were to implement our proposed
patches sir
all right so the question was do we have
any guarantees at all that our patch
will not create additional problems at
the lowest level we only consider
patches that pass all of the regression
tests that you've provided for us so if
there's some important behavior that you
want to make sure that we hold in violet
you need only write a test case for it
and in some sense coming up with an
adequate set of test cases is an
orthogonal software engineering problem
that I won't address here but I will
acknowledge that it's difficult however
it is entirely possible that a patch
that we propose might be parlayed into a
different kind of error for example in
one of the programs that we repair
there's a non buffer overflow based
denial of service attack where people
can send malformed packets that aren't
too long that caused the program to
crash to fail some sort of assertion we
might repair this by removing the
assertion but now the program might
continue on and yeah and do bad things
so it's it's possible that the patches
that we generate could introduce new
security vulnerabilities we will get to
this later in the talk it's an excellent
question and you should be wearing yes
the question was do we make any
assumptions about the impact of the bug
on program state local global and in
general no I'll give you a feel for the
kind of patches and the kind of defects
that were able to repair many of them
such as buffer overrun vulnerabilities
integer overflow attacks deal with
relatively local state but nothing in
the technique assumes it requires that
good question
other questions why we're here okay so
we'll do some experiments on repair
quality which will potentially address
some of these concerns but not all of
them and then there'll be a big finish
so genetic programming formally is the
application of evolutionary or genetic
algorithms to program source code and
whenever you talk about genetic
algorithms at least in my mind there are
three important sort of concepts you
want to get across you need to maintain
a population of variants you need to
modify these programs perhaps with
operations such as crossover and mutate
and then you need to be able to evaluate
the variance to tell which ones are
closer to what you're hoping for and
here for a sort of Microsoft Research
localized example roost and Leno wasn't
able to make it to the talk but I did
get a chance to speak with him yesterday
here a population of variance is sort of
four copies of roost in lane oh and then
we make small modifications so for
example some are standing up some are
sitting down some of a pitcher of apple
juice and at the end of the day we have
to tell which we prefer so for example
if we're very thirsty we might prefer
the roost in with the apple juice right
we're going to do this except that we're
gonna fix programs instead many of you
might be weary of the application of
genetic programming or genetic
algorithms or machine learning to
programming languages or software
engineering tasks you might have seen
these things done in a less than
principled manner in the past another
way to view our work is as search based
software engineering where we're using
the regression test cases to guide the
search they guide both where we make the
modifications and also how we tell when
we're done the picture says what's in a
name that which we call a rose by any
other name would smell as sweet so it's
a quote from Shakespeare about the
naming of things and whether or not that
matters but the font is small and hard
to read a good question so and so how
does this end up working in some sense
there are two secret sauces that allow
us to scale our main claim is that in a
large program not every line is equally
likely to contribute to the bug and
since we required as input indicative
test cases regression tests to make sure
that we're on the right track the
insight is to actually run them and
collect coverage information so we might
do something as simple as instrumenting
the program to print out which lines and
visits and we hypothesize that the bug
is more likely to be found on lines that
are visited when you feed in the
erroneous input right lines that are
visited during sort of the execution of
the negative test case yes
we have okay
the statistical studies
and he found the box a statistic in
those places which are especially common
one entry to explanation that those
places will be working way to
programmers and there's a lot of markup
on there and so they were again in the
game so there was a comment or a
suggestion that even lines of code that
are visited many times might still
contain bugs and we're not going to rule
out portions of the code that are
visited along these positive test cases
but we might weight them less and while
Tom ball is not here he and many other
researchers have looked into fault
localization and to some degree what I'm
going to propose is a very
coarse-grained fault localization we
might imagine using any sort of
off-the-shelf fault localization
technique one of the reasons that we are
perhaps not tempted to do so is that we
want to be able to repair sins of
omission so if the problem with your
program is that you've forgotten a call
you've forgotten a call to free or
forgotten a call to sanitize we still
want to be able to repair that but many
but not all fault localization
techniques tend to have trouble with
bugs that aren't actually present in the
code it's hard to pin it's hard to pin
sins of omission down to a particular
line so we'll start with this and then
later on I will talk about areas where
fault localization or other statistical
techniques might help us good question
yes
puzzling me so you say the bug is more
likely to be found when you're running
the filter so there are also passing
test cases all right so we assume that
you give us a number of regression test
cases that you pass currently and also
one new we call it the negative test
case that encodes the bug some input on
which you crash or get the wrong output
and these existing positive regression
test cases are assumed to encode desired
behavior so we can only repair programs
for which a test suite is available but
there might be some techniques for
automatically generating test cases yes
in the field you collect some crashdown
but then you alright so the question was
about the deployment scenario and in
some sense my answer to this is going to
be both our official story especially at
the beginning of the talk is that we
want to reduce the effort required for
human developers to debug something and
we're going to present to them a
candidate patch that they can look at
that might reduce the amount of time it
takes them to come up with a real patch
so we assume maybe the bug is in the
database there are some steps to
reproduce it you want our tool and five
minutes later we give you a candidate
patch
however our second set of experiments
will involve a deployment scenario we
remove humans from the loop and assume
that some sort of long-running service
has to stay up for multiple days in
there we want to detect perhaps with
anomaly or intrusion detection faults as
they arrive and then try to repair them
so we will address that second scenario
later excellent question though other
questions while we're here okay so we
have the test cases we run them we
notice what parts of the program you
visit we claim that when we're running
this erroneous input that causes the
program to crash or get the wrong answer
that it's likely that those lines have
something to do with the bug however
many programs have let's say a lot of
initialization code at the beginning
that's common maybe you set up some
matrix the same way every time or read
some user configuration file and that
might be code that you visit both on
this negative test case when you're
experiencing the bug but also on all
other positive test case
we want to or we hypothesize that those
lines are slightly less likely to be
associated with about in addition as
we're going around making modifications
to the program we might sometimes delete
lines which is relatively simple but we
might also be tempted to insert or
replace code and when we do if you're
going to insert a line into a c program
there are a large number of statements
or expressions you might choose from
infinite in fact one of the other
reasons that we scale is we're going to
restrict the search space here to code
that's already present in the program in
essence we hypothesize that the program
contains the seeds of its own repair
that if the problem with your program is
for example a null pointer dereference
or an array out of bounds access that
probably somewhere else in your program
you have a null check or you have an
array bounds check following for example
the intuition of Dawson angler bugs is
deviant behavior it's likely that the
programmer gets it right many times but
not every time so rather than trying to
invent new code we're going to copy code
from other parts of your program to try
to fix the bug and I will revisit that
assumption later so we wanted to narrow
down the search space and our formalism
for doing this is a weighted path and
relatively simply for us a weighted path
is a list of statement and weight pairs
where conceptually the weight represents
the likelihood or the probability that
that statement is related to the bug
related to the defect in all of our
experiments we use the following
weighted path the statements are those
that are visited during the failed test
case when we're running the buggy input
and the weights are either very high if
that's a statement that's only visited
on the bug inducing input and not on any
other test case and relatively low if
it's also visited on the other past test
cases if it's that matrix initialization
code that's global 12 runs to the
program sir
and the question was do the way to only
take these values 1.0 and 0.1 for the
experiments that I will be presenting
today
yes we have investigated other weights
so another approach for example would be
to make this zero point one a zero point
zero two just throw out lines in the
program that are also visited on the on
the positive test case and for some runs
of our tool we try different parameter
values in practice these are the highest
performing parameters that we found but
with a very small search it it seems
that our algorithm is in some sense
relatively insensitive to what these
values actually are the question was
about the terminology it's a a list of
statement weight pairs why do I call it
awaited path and the reason is that it's
the path through the program potentially
around loops or through if statements
visited when we execute the failed test
case so it corresponds to a path through
the program but when we throw away the
abstract syntax tree a path is just a
list of steps that you took forward and
then left and whatnot does this answer
your question
yes all right so the question is what is
a test case and I will get to this the
end and show you a concrete example of a
test case from ours but officially we
follow the Oracle comparator model from
software engineering where a test case
is an input that you feed to the program
and it produces new output but you also
have an Oracle somewhere that tells you
what the right output should have been
and in regression testing the Oracle
output is often running the same input
on the last version then there's also a
comparator which could be something very
strict like differ compared which would
notice if even one byte were off but for
something like graphics for example your
comparator might be more fuzzy you might
say oh if part of the picture is blurry
that that doesn't matter as long as the
sum of the squares of the distance is
less than blah blah blah for all of the
cases that I'll present experiments on
we followed a very simple regression
test methodology we ran the sort of
vanilla or the correct version of the
program and wrote down the correct
output all of the output that the
program produced and in order to pass
the test case you had to give exactly
that no more nor less but in theory if
you wanted to only care about certain
output variables our system supports
that so the question is do we care how
many times a statement is executed is
this really a list or is it actually a
set and in our implementation it's
actually a list if you go around the
loop multiple times we will record that
you visited those statements more often
than before so we might be more likely
to look there when we're performing
modifications I'm not going to talk
about our I will skip over our crossover
operator although I will be happy to
answer questions about it in this talk
but in essence it's it requires sort of
in an ordered list and potentially might
care about duplicates we have
investigated and there are options
available for our tool for our prototype
implementation of this treating this
list as a set not considering duplicates
the advantage of this the advantage of
set based approach is that it reduces
the search space the disadvantage is
that we might be throwing away frequency
information about which statements are
actually visited more so the question is
do you want sort of a larger search
space but with a pointer in the right
direction or do you want a smaller
search space that you're choosing from
at random
and we could implement this using a
multiset yes but the the actual sort of
data structure bookkeeping of our
algorithm ends up not being the dominant
cost of this and I'll get into that in a
bit yes
so initially so the question was this
seems to only care about the passing
test cases but the set of statements
that we consider are only those visited
during failed test cases so you can
imagine that statements visited during
neither past nor failed test cases
implicitly get a weight of zero right
and then of those statements during a
failed test cases if they're only
visited on the failed test case they get
high probability otherwise they get low
so both the the positive test cases and
the negative test cases matter and I
have a graphical example to show in a
bit so once we've introduced the
weighted path I can now go back and fit
everything we're doing into a genetic
programming framework need to tell you
what our population of variance is and
for this every every variant program
that we produce is a pair of a standard
abstract syntax tree and also a weighted
path and the weighted path again focuses
our mutations or our program
modifications tells us where we're going
to make the changes once we have a bunch
of these variants we might want to
modify our mutate them and to mutate the
variant we randomly choose a statement
from the weighted path only biased by
the weights so we're more likely to pick
a statement with a high weight once
we've chosen that statement we might
delete it we might replace it with
another statement or we might insert
another statement before after it when
we come up with these new statements
rather than making them up out of whole
cloth we copy them from other parts of
the program this reduces the search
space and helps us to scale and again
this assumes that the program contains
the seeds of its own repair that there's
a null check somewhere else that we can
bring over to help us out we have a
crossover operator that I'm not going to
describe but will happily answer
questions about in some sense it is a
relatively traditional one point
crossover once we have come up with our
variants we want to evaluate them are
they any good are they passing the
test cases we use the regression test
cases and the buggy test case as our
fitness function we have our abstract
syntax tree we pretty print it out to a
C program
pass it to GC C if it doesn't compile we
give it a fitness of zero now since
we're working on the abstract syntax
tree we're never going to get unbalanced
parentheses will never have syntax
errors but we might copy the use of a
variable outside the scope of its
definition so we might fail the type
check if the program fails to compile
for whatever reason we give it a fitness
of zero otherwise we simply run it on
the test cases and it's Fitness is the
number or fraction of test cases that it
passes we might do something like
weighting the buggy test case more than
all of the regression tests if there are
many regression tests but only one way
to reproduce the bug but in general you
can imagine is just counting the number
of test cases passed once we do that we
know the fitness of every variant we
want to retain higher Fitness variants
into the next generation those might be
crossed over with others and we repeat
this process until we find a solution
until we find a variant that passes
every test case or until enough time is
passed no we just let them happen right
and presumably so let's imagine we move
a use of a variable into a scope that
also uses a different variable with the
same name so now we're going to get in
essence random behavior hopefully will
fail a bunch of the test cases so we
won't keep that variant around right on
the other hand that random very random
behavior might be just what we need to
fix the bug unlikely but possible so
we'll consider it but probably it won't
pass the test cases so it won't survive
till the next generation so gonna give a
concrete example of how this works using
idealized source code from the Microsoft
Zune media player and many of you are
perhaps familiar with this code or code
like it
December 31st 2008
some new sources save millions of these
Zune players froze up and in many
reports the calculation that led to the
freeze was something like this we have a
method that's interested in converting a
raw count of days into what the current
year is and in essence this is a while
loop that subtracts 365 from the days
and adds one to the years over and over
again but has some extra processing for
handling leap years right where the day
count is slightly different to see what
might go wrong with this the infinite
loop that causes the players to lock up
imagine that we come in and days is
exactly 366 we're going to go into the
while loop let's say the current year in
1980 is a leap year
if days is greater than 366 well is not
greater then it's exactly equal to so
instead we'll go into this empty else
branch which I've sort of drawn out for
expository purposes right nothing
happens we go around the loop and we'll
go around the loop over and over again
never incrementing or decrementing
variables we loop forever we want to
repair this defect automatically so our
first step is to convert it to an
abstract syntax tree and it should look
similar to before a sign-in sphere we
have this big while loop and what I want
to do is figure out which parts of this
abstract syntax tree are likely to be
associated with the bug we want to find
our weighted path so our first step is
to run the program on some bug inducing
input like ten thousand five hundred
ninety-three which corresponds to
December 31st 2008 and I've highlighted
in pink all of the nodes in the abstract
syntax tree that we visit on this
negative test case we loop forever so
notably we never get to the printf at
the end we visit all of the nodes except
the last one so this is some information
but not a whole lot but now I also want
to remove or weight less nodes that are
visited on positive passing regression
test cases so let's imagine that we know
what the right answer is supposed to be
when days equal 1000 we have a
regression test for it I rerun the
program and also mark in here I'm
marking in green all of the nodes that
were visited on positive test cases and
in some sense the difference between
them is going to be my weighted path I'm
going to largely restrict attention to
just this node down here which is
visited on negative test case but on no
positive
cases so here's my weighted path once I
have the weighted path I might randomly
apply mutation operations insertions
deletions replacements but only two
nodes along the weighted path let's
imagine I I get relatively lucky the
first time I choose to do an insertion
right where am I going to insert I'm
more or less stuck inserting here and
rather than inventing code whole cloth
I'm going to copy a statement from
somewhere else in the program so for
example I might copy this days- equal
366 statement and insert it into this
block once I do the final code ends up
looking somewhat like this I now have a
copy of that node I've changed the
program slightly different abstract
syntax tree and this ends up being our
final repair it passes all of our
previous test cases and it doesn't loop
forever on the negative test case and in
but it's but it might not be what a
human would have done and it might not
be it might not be correct maybe our
negative test case wasn't correct so I'm
gonna talk a bit in a bit about repair
quality yes essentially you will be
trying to add code to the exception
handler to make it repaired but the bug
might be some that is so ok so this is a
good point for the implementation that
we have here we've been concentrating on
off-the-shelf C programs we're in sort
of standard standard C exception
handling is not an option we have
previously published work for repairing
vulnerabilities if a specification is
given right and in that work we
specifically described how to add or
remove exception handling either try
catch or try finally statements in order
to fix up type state problems for
example if we were going to move this to
say Java or some other language with
exception handling we would probably try
to carry over some of those ideas so we
haven't implemented it yet currently our
implementation is C there are no major
problems preventing us from moving to
other languages but there are corner
cases we would want to think about such
as exception handling so for example if
we were moving to a language with
exception handling we might want to
consider adding syntax
Trier catcher finally as atomic mutation
actions more on that in a bit
so before we get to repair quality it's
just sort of a brief show of how this
happened overtime on this graph the the
dark bar shows the Fitness we assigned
to our the average our overall
population of variants as time or as
generation goes by and in this
particular version we had five normal
regression test cases that were worth
one point each and we had two test cases
that reproduce the bug and passing those
that is not looping forever getting the
right answer was worth 10 points each
and we start off at five we pass all of
the normal regression tests but none of
the buggy tests after one generation our
score is now up at ten or eleven we
passed one of the buggy tests but have
lost key functionality we're no longer
passing some of the regression tests
around we're at 12 instead of 15 and are
our favorite variant the variant that
eventually goes on to become the
solution stays relatively stable for a
while the others sort of generally
increase until eventually either it's
mutated or it combines part of its
solution with something else that's
doing relatively well and in this
seventh generation it passes all of the
regression test cases as well as the two
bugs so we think about this for a while
this is an iterative process and then
hopefully at the end we pass all the
test cases yes
this is a great question and in fact we
have we have these numbers although I do
let us say that less than half of the
variants that we generate failed to
compile and I can get you the the actual
numbers right after this presentation if
we were to operate on source code and it
was possible that we could make mistakes
with balanced parentheses or curly
braces then it would be a much higher
fraction and we'll return to that in a
bit so we maintain a population to
variance let's say 40 random versions of
the same program and we will mutate all
of them and then run them all on the
test cases and then keep the top half
say to form the next generation and the
average here is the average fitness of
all 40 members of that generation that
population so I made the first some of
this to the local expert but my answer
would go along these lines genetic
programming or genetic algorithms are a
heuristic search strategy somewhat like
simulated annealing that you would use
to it to explore a large space and one
of the reasons you would be tempted to
use something like this instead of say
Newton's method is that you want to
avoid the problems associated with hill
climbing you want to avoid getting stuck
in a local maximum and the crossover
operation in genetic programming or
genetic algorithms which I haven't
talked about holds out the possibility
of combining information from one
variant that's stuck in a local hill
over here and say in the second part of
the path with another variant that's
stuck in a hill over here say in the
first part of the path we might take
those two things and merge them together
and suddenly jump up and break out of
the problems associated with local hill
climbing so the hope is that this this
is the sort of thing that we would get
out of using this particular heuristic
search strategy but I will defer to the
local expert
population because the average is so
even though that individual was it was
good enough to keep being copied
unchanged into the next generation but
it was no obviously not the best
individual left in the population in the
end the question was between 3 & 4
nothing moved between 3 & 4 the averages
didn't move but the population size is
let's say 40 or 80 this so I must
apologize for the misleading label here
in our terminology the best individual
is the one that eventually forms the
repair eventually so we're tracking a
single person or a single individual
from the dawn of time to the end yes see
Traci should a single individual
but it's an artifact accompany to our
culture
hmm yes
for this particular repair let's say 300
seconds three or four slides from now I
will I will present quantitative results
on average for any of the 15 programs
that we can repair the average time to
repair is 600 seconds so once we do this
we apply mutation for a while we come up
with a bunch of variants we evaluate
them by running them on the test cases
eventually we find one that passes all
the test cases this is our candidate for
the repair our patch that we might
present to developers is simply the diff
between the original program and the
variant that passes all the test cases
we just pretty print it out and take the
diff however random mutation may have
added unneeded statements or may have
changed behavior that's not captured in
any of your test cases we might have
inserted dead code or redundant
computation and we don't want to waste
developer time with that right the
purpose of this was to give them
something good to look at so in essence
we're going to take a look at our deer
for our patch which is sort of a list of
things to do to the program and consider
removing every line from the patch if we
did all of the patch except line three
would that still be enough to make us
pass all of the test cases if so then we
don't need line three
then line three was redundant and you
could imagine trying all combinations
but that might be computationally
infeasible or take exponential time
instead we use the well-known Delta
debugging approach to find a one minimal
subset of the diff in N squared time
where one minimal means that if even a
single line of the patch were removed it
wouldn't cause us to pass all of the
test cases so and once again rather than
working at the raw concrete syntax level
rather than using standard if we use a
tree structure diff algorithm defects in
particular to avoid problems with
balanced curly braces we're removing one
would cause the patch to be invalid and
not compile
program I mean every line of the program
rather than just
Frances of the Camden with
the life that they're actually in the
original program
okay so this is a good question mm-hmm
let me see if I can give an example of
this let's say that the original program
is a b c and the fix is a b d something
like that then our first patch will be
something like delete c and insert d at
the appropriate location right there are
two parts of this patch these are the
only things that we're going to be
considering when we minimize sets so
when we talk about minimizing the patch
the possibilities that we're considering
are one alone one two two or none of
these so we're we're never going to
remove a so we're not going to
mistakenly go back and hurt the original
program it's it's only among the changes
that were made by genetic algorithms we
say did we actually need all of those so
this is a great idea is a great question
and we have a number of ideas related to
it the question was why are we trying to
minimize the size of the patch and not
some other objective our initial
formulation of this was we wanted to
present it to developers and often when
developers make patches to working code
you want to do the least harm you want
to touch as little as possible right
however we have been considering
applying this technique to other domains
for example let's imagine that you're a
graphics person interested in pixel or
vertex shaders which are loaded onto a
graphics processor right those are small
C programs rather than trying to repair
them might retry to use genetic
programming or the same sort of mutation
to create an optimized version of a
vertex or pixel shader that is faster
but perhaps produces slightly blurry or
output but since it will be viewed by a
human we might not care so here our test
cases would be not an exact match but
instead the l 2-norm could be off by 10%
and rather than favoring the smallness
of the change we would favour the
performance of the resulting program so
that is a good idea we're certainly
considering things like that for now for
the basic presentation we want to get to
the essence of the defect to help the
question was a smaller change might
influence a method that's called more
frequently also a tick see one of my
students will be presenting work on
statically predicting or statically
guessing the relative dynamic execution
frequency of paths one of the other
areas we've been considering for this is
rather than breaking ties in terms of
size break term or break ties in terms
of this changes less likely to be
executed in the real world right so we
might have a static way of detecting
that or we might use the dynamic counts
that we have from your existing
regression test case assuming they're
indicative and use those to break the
tie instead also a great idea
other questions while we're here so does
it work yes so here we have initial
results all in all we've been able to
repair about 15 programs totaling about
140,000 lines of code off-the-shelf c
programs on the left I have the names of
the programs some of them may well be
familiar who F T P D is a favorite
whipping boy for its many
vulnerabilities for PHP interpreter
graphical Tetris game flex indent and D
raw for standard sort of UNIX utilities
Lloyd httpd and knowledge CTP dear web
servers and open LDAP is a web based
Directory authentication protocol in the
next column we've got the lines of code
and for a number of these open LDAP
ladies DPD or PHP it's worth noting that
we are not performing the whole program
analysis for these
we want to show that we can repair just
a single module out of an entire program
open LDAP is relatively large we're only
going to concentrate on modifying i/o
dot C perhaps someone has already been
able to localize the error to there for
the rest of these graphical Tetris game
FTP server we perform as a whole program
analysis we merge the entire program
together into one conceptual file and do
the repair from there so here's the
lines of code that we operated on the
next column over shows something that's
perhaps more relevant to us the size of
the weighted path this can be viewed as
a proxy for the size of the search space
that we have to look through in order to
potentially find the repair recall that
we only perform mutations insertions and
deletions along this weighted path as we
go through and create variants we have
to evaluate them we apply our fitness
function we run all of the test cases
against each variant to see how well
it's doing this ends up being the
dominant performance cost in our
approach running your entire test suite
55 times might actually take a
significant amount of wall clock time
although it can be parallelized at a
number of levels so in this column we
report the number of times we would have
to run your entire test suite before we
came up with this repair and finally on
the right I have a description of the
sorts of defects that we're repairing
initially we started off by reproducing
results from the original fuzz testing
work which was on UNIX utilities you
feed them garbage input they crash so
for many of these like Adira off or
indent we found a number of segmentation
violations or infinite loops that we
were able to repair then we moved more
towards security we went back through
old security mailing lists bug track
that kind of thing and found exploits
that people had posted say against web
servers or against open LDAP and for
these sorts of things PHP atreus leaded
speedy open LDAP the negative test case
is a published exploit by some blackhat
and then we try to repair the program
until it's immune to that
so defects include things as varied as
format string vulnerabilities integer
overflows stack and heap buffer
overflows segmentation violations
infinite loops non overflow denials of
service yes
ah this is a good question so for many
of these we were able to get away with
relatively small test Suites let's say
five or six test cases that encode
required behavior however in many cases
we expect there to be more test cases
available rather than less so I'll
return to test case prioritization or
test case reduction or our scaling
behavior as test cases increase in just
a bit for right now we're only using
five or six test cases and we're still
able to come up with decent repairs yes
of the first 15 we tried in some sense
everything we tried succeeded although
recently we have found a number of
programs that we are unable to succeed
at we might be unable to succeed at this
is this is such a great idea that it
will occur to slice for now we will we
will test in just a bit whether or not
we can use the software after applying
the repair so excellent idea yes how do
we read the fitness numbers this is the
number of times I had to run your entire
test case your entire test suite before
I came up with the repair so for example
to fix the format string vulnerability
in woof TPD I had to run its test suite
55 times yes there are such lessons I
will get to them on the next slide and
we'll talk about scalability in just a
bit yes
after minimization the average patch
size was four to five lines so we 2/10
we tended to be able to fix things or we
tended to produce fixes that were
relatively local and I'll talk about
that qualitatively in a bit often our
repairs were not what a human would have
done not succeed because you change say
they make mixing in the day of the
talking
chances are the black hat like a score
is great so I'm not sure so what is your
metric for success all right so the
question was for a number of security
attacks they're relatively fragile in
any small change mighty to defeat them
to some degree great now if a small
change does defeat it less facetiously
for many of these for open LDAP or for
PHP or for example we searched around
until we found an exploit that was
relatively sophisticated for example
exploits that did automatic searching
for stack offsets and layouts so that
even if we changed the size of the stack
they would still succeed for the format
string vulnerability 1 we used an
exploit that searched dynamically for
legitimate format strings often finding
ones that were 300 characters long or
whatnot so the relatively simple changes
where you add a single character and now
the the executable is one byte larger
and it's immune we tried to come up with
negative test cases that would see
through that another way to approach
that is we also manually inspected and
we described this in the XT paper all of
the resulting repairs and are able to
tell whether or not a similar attack
would succeed and in general what
actually happens is we do defeat the
attack but only there let's imagine that
you have a buffer overrun vulnerability
rampant throughout your code and your
negative test case shows one particular
read that can take over we'll fix that
one read but not the three others
and there's a trivial solution to the
problem right now it's just you there
are some specific input that you didn't
want not you don't want just block those
that's it right not only it's faster
it's 100% precise we respect for that
specific this week and second in the
discerning date case is the passing test
you sure that the functionality hasn't
been out right so Patrice is describing
fast signature generation an approach
that we find orthogonal to ours there is
nothing wrong with signature generation
we like it a lot in fact we want to
encourage you to use it to buy us time
to come up with the real repair right so
one of the tricks with fast and precise
signature generation is that you
actually often can't get all of those
adjectives at the same time if you are
just blocking that particular input then
the blackhat changes one character and
they get past your what not if you're
trying to block a large class of inputs
then often you're using regular
expressions or somesuch at the network
level and you also block legitimate
traffic we're going to end up evaluating
our technique using the same sorts of a
same sorts of metrics you would use to
evaluate signature generation to wit the
amount of time it takes us to do it and
the number of transactions lost later
and you'll be able to compare for
yourself quantitatively whether or not
we've done a good job right but we do
want to use signature generation it's
orthogonal
you start with more than one negative
test case and I assume that your
technique once with one Indian test is
at the time so you see if you change the
different order of the degree of test
cases that you consider and you end up
with the same batch this is a good idea
officially we can actually support
multiple negative test cases we just
keep going until you pass every test
case so having multiple there at the
same time doesn't hurt us but in some
sense we might we have no reason to
believe that our repair operation is
distributive it might be easier for us
to fix two things alone than to fix them
both at the same time your robustness
measurement is intriguing
we should talk after the presentation
impossible test was going to fail so
what is the negative test is going to
become a positive test when you consider
the next negative yes we you're correct
yes other questions while we're here
yeah so in general this worked out
relatively well for us rather than the
lines of code in the program the size of
the weighted path ended up being a big
determining factor and how long it took
to come up with the repair question for
the front no I should wrap up now so our
our scalability is largely related to
the length of this weighted path the
length of the weighted path is sort of a
proxy for the search space that we have
to explore here we've plotted a number
of things that we can repair note log
log scale right but in general this is
one of the areas where we might use some
sort of off-the-shelf
fault localization technique from
Tomball or whatnot for the cases that
have particularly long-awaited paths
certainly
it's less than quadratic and a little
more than linear
so in general there are pairs that we
come up with are not what a human would
have done for example I talked about
this before we might add bounced checks
to one area in your code rather than
rewriting the program to use the safe
abstract string class which is what
humans might do when presented with
evidence of the bug in one area it is
worth noting that any proposed repair we
come up with must pass all of the
regression tests that you give us one
way to view this is for one of the
things that we repair this web server
the vulnerability is that it trusts the
content length provided by the user the
user can provide a large negative number
when posting information when uploading
images or whatnot allowing the remote
user to take control of the web server
if we don't include any regression tests
for post functionality the repair that
we come up with very fast is to disable
post functionality we just remove that
you're no longer allowed to do that
which in some sense might actually be
better than the standard approach of
running the server and read-only mode
because in read-only mode you could
still get access to confidential
information
but in general we require that the user
provide us with a sufficiently rich test
suite to ensure all functionality and
that's an orthogonal problem in software
engineering our minimization process in
some sense also prevents gratuitous
deletions you know to functionality and
not shown here adding more test cases
say moving up to 20 or a hundred helps
us rather than hurting us right so we
still succeed about the same fraction of
the time if there are more test cases so
in brief limited time you might also
want to look at repair quality another
way imagine you're in some sort of
e-commerce security setting like your
amazon.com or pets.com and you're
selling dogs to people over the internet
from your perspective a high quality
repair might be one that blocks security
attacks while still allowing you to sell
as many dogs as possible without
reducing transactional throughput so to
test this to test our repair and sort of
a self-healing setting we integrated
with an anomaly intrusion detection
system basic idea here is we throw an
indicative workload at you and when the
anomaly detection system flags the
requests as possibly an attack we set it
aside and treat it as the buggy test
case and try to repair the program said
it's not vulnerable to that the danger
to this is that we can do this repair
without humans in the loop and what
yes just dogs and loop so let's see how
that actually goes our experimental
setup was to obtain indicative workloads
we then apply the workload to a vanilla
server sped up so that the server is
brought to its knees and the reason
we're doing this is so that any
additional overhead introduced by the
repair process or the patch shows up on
measurement right we then send some
known attack packet the intrusion
detection system Flags it we take the
server down during the repair measure
how many packets we lose then we apply
the repair and then we send the workload
again
all right measuring the throughput after
we apply the repair which is sort of
equivalent to measuring the precision of
a filter does this work in fact it
worked relatively well we started out
with workloads about 140,000 requests
for two different web servers and also
we considered a dynamic web application
written in PHP that ran on top of web
servers the sort of room an item
reservation system each row here is
individually normalized so that the
vanilla version before the repair is
considered to have 100% performance
right however many requests it's able to
serve as the right amount we send it the
indicative workload once and then we
send the attack packet and try to come
up with a repair for that attack in each
case the attacks were again
off-the-shelf security vulnerabilities
from bug Trac we were able to generate
one of these repairs one of the first
questions is how long did it take are we
as fast as fast signature generation and
assuming that there's one such attack
per day in general we lose between let's
say zero and three percent of your
transactional throughput if you take the
server down to do the repair in general
you might imagine having a failover or
backup server in read-only mode say that
might handle requests during this time
so for us the more important number is
what happens after we deploy the repair
might we deploy low-quality repairs that
caused us to fail to sell dogs and in
essence the answer is no any any
transactions or any packets that we lost
after applying the repair were totally
lost in the noise and our definition of
success was relatively stringent success
here means not only that we got the
output byte for byte correct but also
that we did it in the same amount of
time or less than it took the vanilla
unmodified program
and the reason for this the
interpretation is that our positive test
cases the regression test prevent us
from sacrificing key functionality
there's a question this is a great idea
we had not considered it but we will now
the question was could we compare our
throughput loss to that of a Web
Application Firewall like in the new
named one in particular
yes yes the outputs we only count it as
a successful request if it's exactly the
same yes so yes I will get to this in
and let's say a minute
this is a great question whenever we
start using an intrusion or anomaly
detection system false positives become
a fact of life an intrusion detection
system might mistakenly point out some
innocuous request as if it were an error
so a second set of experiments we did
here was let's take some false positives
let's take some requests like get
indexed at HTML that are not actually
attacks pretends their attacks and try
to repair them and see what happens
right maybe then we come up with a
low-quality repair so we did that three
times
we took completely legitimate requests
and considered them to be attacks and
try to repair them in two of the cases
we were actually able to make some sort
of repair and I'll quantify for you in
just a second what that might mean in
general it takes us a long time to come
up with repairs for things that aren't
actually problems because we have to
search through the space until we find
some sort of corner case way of in
essence tabulating defeating this
particular input but allowing all others
to get through in fact in our third
false positive it was in essence get
indexed at HTML and there was no way to
both fail this and also pass this as one
of the regression tests so we couldn't
make or a pair there but even for these
two times where we did come up with
repairs that in some sense weren't
actually valid or repaired non bugs any
transactional throughput that we that we
might have suffered at the end was in
the noise because again we have these
sort of positive regression test cases
that make us keep important
behavior around what are examples of
packets that we might lose for one of
these the repair involved in some cases
dropping the cache-control tag from the
HTTP response header previously yes you
are allowed to cache it with our bad
repair in some of these cases no you
weren't allowed to cache it so maybe
then you have to make extra requests of
the server in order to get the same data
so you don't get everything done in time
so you drop a few packets there
that is that your test case no this is a
great question no no no no I will we
have a five separate test cases get
indexed at HTML post my name and copy it
back to me get a directory get a jiff
and get a file that's not found those
are our five test cases yes those the
ones we check every time yes
so the repair never sees these 138,000
requests in our one out of 130,000 the
workload is entirely benign we play the
workload once we send the attack and
then we play the workload again the
attack is in off the shelf exploit from
bug track it buries by which program
exactly the same as it becomes the
negative test case that we use to
generate there's only one of them there
are by ends of it what would you feed
the trivial solution of just blocking
that specific input in this experiment
if you did the trivial solution of
blocking that particular input you would
get a high score we did not do the
trivial solution of blocking that
particular input which you cannot tell
from this chart but I assert and we
describe qualitatively in text right and
in in essence what we want to say is the
trivial solution we do really well
perfect filtering would do really well
we also do really well but we are
repairing the problem and not just
putting a bandaid on top or still we
claim
you're basically giving a lot of weight
is too small genius we're not going to
in that new code right so other
limitations beyond those that have been
brought out by a student audience
members one is that we can't handle
non-deterministic faults we run your
program and all the test cases and
assume that's going to tell us whether
it's correct or not and if you have
something like a race condition running
it once might not be able to tell us
what's going on now we did handle
multi-threaded programs like web servers
but those aren't really multi-threaded
because the copies don't actually
communicate with each other in any
interesting way a long term potential
solution to this might be to put
scheduler constraints perhaps related to
controlling interleavings into the
variant representation said a repair
would be both changed these five lines
of code and also instruct the virtual
machine not to do the following schedule
or swap future work we also assume that
the buggy test case visits different
lines of code than the normal regression
test cases for something like a
cross-site scripting attack or a sequel
code injection vulnerability that would
not be the case right and then our
weighted path wouldn't be a good way to
narrow down the search space and in such
an area we might want to use an
off-the-shelf fault localization
approach like Tom balls finally we also
assume that existing statements the
program can help form the repair
currently we're working on some notion
of repair templates something like
type--the runtime code generation sort
of the essence of a null check is if
some hole is not null than some hole for
statements we can imagine either
handcrafting those or mining them from
version control repositories maybe you
work in a company where there's been a
lot of changes related to switching over
to wide character support moving from
printf to WS printf if we notice that
other divisions are doing that then
maybe we can suggest that as repairs for
you sir
so you're worried about with the dogs a
soul don't know yes still you may
how many builders so so in this
connection there is one generalizations
that have passed being yes no that's
giving numbers and then you can optimize
yes one so this is a good idea one of
the reasons that we haven't pursued it
experimentally is that in the open
source world it is hard to find test
cases that are that fine-grained that
have a real number value rather than yes
or no but Microsoft may well have them
and before everyone leaves there will be
sort of a beg athon where I ask for a
yes the real reason we're here help from
Microsoft so the work that I've
presented here covers actually two
papers and more HD work that we
presenting in a few days which in
essence describes our repair algorithm
that you know the test cases that we use
the repair quality answers the question
does this approach work at all it's
controversial you know yes it looks like
it does we have a second paper in the
genetic and evolutionary computing
conference coming out a bit later which
answers questions related to our
crossover and mutation operations is
this really evolutionary computing or is
this perhaps just random search right
what are the effects of more test cases
what's the scaling behavior questions
more related to why does this work in
general though we claim that we can
automatically and efficiently repair
certain classes of bugs and
off-the-shelf legacy programs we use
regression tests to encode the desired
behavior and also to focus the search on
parts of the program that we view are
more likely to contain the bugs so we
use regression tests rather than say
manual annotations mm-hmm meant
I encourage difficult questions and
there have been a number already any
last questions
you know it's like this grows I would
love to I mean the idea of course you
would prove that or I mean that you have
more verification because tested of the
repaired programs actually semantically
equivalent functionally equivalent to
the faulty one might accept one thing
yes so we have some previous work for
automatically generating repairs in the
presence of a specification where the
repair provably adheres to the
specification and doesn't introduce any
new violations one of the things we
wanted to do here was see how far we
could get without specifications without
specifications it's harder to talk about
things like proof one of the directions
we've been considering instead is
documentation we have some previous work
that was successful at automatically
generating documentation for
object-oriented programs could we extend
that work to automatically document what
we think is going on in the exception
I'm sorry what we think is going on in
the repair and that it might be even
easier for the developer to say no the
tool is way off I don't want to do this
or oh this is the right idea but I
should add one more line or somesuch
we have also been considering imagine
someone has some specifications but not
all of them and also some test case I
know I know it's hard to believe
and then also some test cases is there
some way we could incorporate
information from specifications into our
fitness function right or to sort of
guide the repair so if we do have any
sort of partial correctness
specification we can be certain that we
never generate a repair that causes a
tool or a model checker to think that
the resulting program violates a partial
correctness specification assuming
they're present maybe I made that part
but a critical part seems to be which
tests you pick the positive test
because reality I don't know any party
going yes five test case right sweet
representative and then multiply it by
the number of yes right going right I
can't see where you're going so it might
take a very long time so in fact we have
current work not described here on using
in essence either randomization or test
suite reduction there's been a lot of
previous work in the software
engineering community on let's say time
aware test suite prioritization may be
using knapsack solvers may be using
other approaches to perhaps order test
cases by code coverage may be doing the
first ones and then sort of bailing out
in a short-circuit manner if you fail
some obvious test at the beginning now
we have a student currently working on
let's imagine you have a hundred test
cases subsampling for each fitness
evaluation just pick ten of them or just
to pick five of them use that for your
fitness score but then if you think
you've won then we run you on all 100 of
them thus far using relatively simple
techniques like that we've been able to
get to 95% performance improvements so
we have reason to believe that we might
be able to apply off-the-shelf software
engineering test suite reduction
techniques in the case where you have
hundreds of hundreds or thousands of
test cases rather than five you did that
was the design I'm not convinced or well
running test cases I mean you're
assuming the test is actually what
written you might just try to destroy
the machine or ask you mean that your
test cases by understand correctly for
this to work and that they are really
hard there are very low level and they
are qualified quite a bit beyond good so
that's basic concrete input and we're
very specified completely defined input
I get that completely defined output you
cannot have a test case saying all your
code has to be greater than zero you
could turn look good but then it's not
gonna work because again you could very
well then generate basically a lot of
different repairs there are going to
basically
then the repaired program will be
completely different functionally
speaking than the original one you see
when I'm yes so we have not studied that
again we claim that if you if what you
really want the program to be doing is
not returning any number greater than
zero then your test case shouldn't just
pass it if it returns any number greater
than zero we'd say it's your
responsibility to make a more precise
test case in that scenario based on the
default that might be very expensive by
itself you might be less expensive than
a retest all methodology guess is what
we're currently doing it might still be
expensive but we are still in the early
stages of dealing with programs with
more test cases and one of the reasons
that we're still in the early stages is
that they don't exist in the open source
world so if you in Microsoft have many
test cases and you would like to
contribute to a worthy goal you might
want to consider the converse of that is
that if you had a formal specification
you also wouldn't need any repairs how
much of the global state gets affected
because of the patch did you generate
yes I mean I suppose you know you pause
the test cases but you introduce some
behavior that only shows yes so ideally
speaking you'd want to minimize the
impact the program has on yes this is a
good idea would we notice if we enter
with we added a memory leak and we
probably would not unless you already
had a test case for it officially as a
standard test case practice all of these
test cases should be run in a change
rooted jail or in a virtual machine or
whatnot lest we introduce the command RM
star dot star if we're already one
running under a virtual machine then
checking things like memory memory areas
that you're touching is is potentially
more feasible we have not
about this but this is a great idea we
should look more into it other questions
so I think your premise has been that
programs containing seeds of their own
they appear yes just some programs so
basically horrible so in those cases
would it be possible to use the
abundance to introduce some sort of
pollination this I think the answer to
this is yes this would be a good idea we
had not thus far considered it we've
been sort of stuck in our repair
templates mode where you can see some of
the seeds of this as it were seeing from
a different division in your company to
bring over repairs but in essence this
is a different question which is when
we're doing you know mutation to insert
statements might we draw from a
different statement Bank than the
original program maybe a better high
quality statement Bank or one that has
been winnowed down to contain an only
good stuff or what not it's a great idea
we have not considered it but it is
likely that it would do better than what
we're doing now